g
f
y what at that stand
for listen to this now Gutfeld is a
truth teller in the first place but
watch how he got a little extra Brave
here at the end of this segment from a
couple days ago how do you think then
about the economics of of x if if if if
part of the underlying model at least
today and maybe it needs to shift maybe
the answer is it needs to shift away
from
advertising um if if you believe that
this is the one part of your business
where you will be beholden to those who
uh have this
view what do you do f
y g
f
y what could that stand
for gutfeld's freaking
yummy but he's got a point how insane is
it that companies are trying to
Blackmail the world's richest man with
money
that's like extorting Jerry Nadler with
salad or blackmailing sports fans by
threatening to cancel
PBS the fact is musk may be the last man
standing between real freedom of speech
and the suffocating block of the
censorship industrial complex which is
made up of government media and Tech
forces he realizes that advertisers have
no spine and can be easily cowed by
special interest groups in cahoots with
political allies if you don't believe me
I got two words for you Tucker
Carlson
wow look at
that you think courage begets courage I
mean think about that right you heard
what tuck what Greg says there he then
says Tucker crosson basically saying hey
my network the channel That this thing's
on right now took out that guy he knows
what he's about to say is going to kind
of get him into crap the audience starts
laughing then reverses the laugh that's
not what usually happens at these shows
and the panelists are all like whoa hey
whoa what show are we
on you get the point guys you get the
point and by the way if big Pharma
bailes on Fox if big Pharma bailes on
MSNBC and every else they don't know
where they're going to get their
advertisers so I give my friend Greg
Gutfeld an awful lot of
credit